las leyes de la naturaleza no son más
que los pensamientos de dios está de
aquí es una frase bien bonita de
euclides euclides de alejandría que fue
un filósofo y matemático que vivió
trescientos años antes de cristo hay un
kleenex se le considera el padre de la
geometría déjame ponerle por aquí
geometría geometría y esta frase la puse
porque me parece una frase bien bonita
es una frase muy linda
independientemente de tus creencias
religiosas
más bien me parece que lo importante de
esta frase es que nos está hablando de
una relación entre la naturaleza y entre
las matemáticas y eso es una idea
fantástica pero bueno vamos a platicar
un poco acerca de la geometría geometría
viene de dos raíces griegas geo que
quiere decir tierra y metría que tiene
que ver con medir seguramente has
escuchado acerca del sistema métrico que
tiene todo que ver en el mundo con medir
vale bueno a youkilis se le considera el
padre de la geometría no porque haya
sido el primero en hacer geometría de
hecho es muy fácil imaginarse a nuestros
antepasados viendo no sé ramas en el
suelo digamos unas ramas así y otras
ramas así y dándose cuenta que estas
ramas de alguna forma están más
separadas o más abiertas que estas ramas
de acá a lo mejor incluso las comparaban
con conoce con un tronco de un árbol y
veían que había algo en común entre esta
apertura y esta apertura de acá o
incluso es fácil imaginar los no sé
pensando en algunos círculos a lo mejor
se preguntaban cuál era la razón de la
distancia de recorrer el círculo
alrededor y atravesarlo y seguramente se
sorprendieron mucho cuando se dieron
cuenta que esa razón no dependía del
tamaño del círculo pero bueno estos son
así los antepasados más antiguos si
avanzamos un poco la película llegamos a
grecia y nos encontramos con con
personas que empezaron a pensar un poco
más seriamente en la geometría como por
ejemplo pitágoras sin embargo a
pitágoras no se le conoce como el padre
de la geometría y a euclides sí por
cierto estoy aquí es de euclides este de
aquí es euclides y esta imagen es un
fragmento de una pintura hecha por
rafael claro rafael y euclides no
vivieron al mismo tiempo esto
simplemente es una interpretación de
cómo se imaginaba rafael que euclides
daba sus clases pero bueno lo que hace a
euclides el padre de la geometría es
haber escrito este libro de acá que se
llama los elementos
ponerle aquí elementos
elementos y este libro de los elementos
era una colección de 13 sub libros tres
de sus libros que forman un camino
lógico y riguroso en varias en varias
áreas de las matemáticas en teoría de
números en geometría del plano y en
geometría del espacio este es
básicamente un libro de texto pero
argumentable mente es el libro de texto
más conocido de toda la historia esta
imagen de acá es una imagen de la
primera traducción que se tuvo en inglés
pero en realidad los elementos de
euclides se han bueno se han traducido a
muchísimos idiomas empezaron por
supuesto en griego en griego después los
árabes hicieron su propia traducción
árabe árabe después del árabe se pasó al
latín y latín y de ahí ya se empezó a
traducir a muchísimas lenguas entre
ellas el inglés y el español le voy a
poner aquí inglés porque es porque es la
imagen de acá vale bueno ahora a lo que
me refiero con un camino riguroso en
varias áreas de la matemática es a lo
siguiente por ejemplo pitágoras tenía su
teorema y estaba muy feliz con el desear
el cuadrado de los lados de un triángulo
rectángulo bueno cuando sumamos esos dos
cuadrados nos queda el cuadrado de la
hipotenusa después practicaremos un poco
más con calma de eso pero bueno
pitágoras tenía ese teorema que era un
resultado y lo usaba era algo que se dio
cuenta que era cierto y lo usaba
constantemente sin embargo la euclides
no le satisface simplemente usar los
resultados y puedes pensar que
probablemente sean ciertos lo que
utilices quieres estar totalmente seguro
de que todos los resultados que usa son
así ciertos sin lugar a dudas para eso
hace un sistema bien bonito casi un
sistema en el cual hay algunos
resultados básicos algunos enunciados
básicos más bien a los que les llama
axiomas o postulados y luego a partir de
esos postulados empieza a probar algunas
cosas y pues no tan obvias más más
interesantes por ejemplo a lo mejor
contando este con este prueba un teorema
por acá y también prueba que algunas
cosas son falsas por ejemplo tal vez
usando este prueba que que esta de acá
es falsa pero luego lo que está padre es
que se pueden combinar todas estas
y probando otros resultados y a lo mejor
juntando este con este obtenemos un
teorema que está todavía más más padre
vale bueno lo especial de este sistema
es que nadie se le había ocurrido antes
hacer esto en toda la historia de la
ciencia no estaba esta idea de prueba
rigurosa en la cual se iba haciendo una
pirámide de resultados en la cual pues
se probaban cada vez cosas más y más
impresionantes y esto tuvo tanto impacto
que por 2000 años la gente no te
consideraba bien educada si no habías
leído y meditado a euclides de hecho
este libro se volvió tan importante que
fue el segundo más impreso en toda la
historia en toda la historia este
occidental después de la biblia entonces
esto está padrísimo verdad es un libro
de texto es un libro de matemáticas que
está solo detrás de la biblia en
cantidad de impresiones eso está muy muy
padre y bueno para darnos una idea de un
pasado un poco más reciente y ver que
los elementos de euclides realmente eran
importantes déjame déjame ponerte una
cita que tengo aquí abajo bueno
dependerá de
si piensas que algunas décadas es un
poco más reciente pero bueno estoy acá
es una cita de abraham lincoln uno de
los presidentes de eeuu más importantes
esta foto de acá me gusta mucho porque
muestra a lincoln un poco más joven de
lo que usualmente lo muestran otras
fotos aquí tenía como treinta y tantos
años y resulta que el lincoln lincoln
era un gran fan de los elementos de
euclides lo leía en su casa lo leía en
la casa blanca de hecho tenemos esta
cita de acá déjame leerte la dice en el
3 en el transcurso de mi lectura en
leyes constantemente me encontraba con
la palabra demostrar demostrar esta
palabra de acá pensé que al inicio
entendía su significado pero pronto me
convencí de que no era así me dije a mí
mismo qué hago cuando demuestro que no
se hace cuando razonó o pruebo entonces
aquí se ve que el lincoln está pensando
en demostrar como una cosa no sé como
una cosa que requiere más pensamiento
que razonar o probar vale es como una
prueba más especial sigue en qué sentido
la demostración es distinta de cualquier
otra prueba consulte el diccionario
webster este es un diccionario bien
famoso que ya existía por las épocas de
lincoln entonces si se consulta el
diccionario western y ahí hablaban de
prueba certera
prueba más allá de cualquier posibilidad
de duda pero no podía imaginar qué tipo
de prueba sería esta pensé que muchas
cosas estaban probadas más allá de
cualquier posibilidad de duda sin
recurrir a un proceso de razonamiento
tan extraordinario como el que entendía
que era una demostración aquí se ve que
sigue pensando que es un proceso así
superimportante vale
luego nos dice consulte todos los
diccionarios y libros de referencia que
pude encontrar pero sin mejores
resultados era como si le definiera azul
a un hombre ciego está este está muy
bonita definir un color a un hombre
ciego debe ser algo algo muy difícil
pero bueno
lincoln dice al final dije se habla a sí
mismo lincoln nunca podrás ser un
abogado si no entiendes que es una
demostración y abandoné mis estudios en
springfield fui a casa de mi padre y me
quedé ahí hasta que pudiera dar
cualquier proposición en los seis libros
los seis libros se refiere a los de
geometría plana a simple vista entonces
descubrí que quiere decir demostrar y
regresé a mi estudio crece a mi estudio
en leches entonces esto está padrísimo
aquí tenemos una cita de uno de los
presidentes americanos buenos
estadounidenses más importantes y vemos
que el lincoln sentía que para ser
realmente un buen abogado tenía que
entender pues los elementos de euclides
y además poder dar la demostración de
cualquier proposición a simple vista y
bueno eso después lo extrapoló y lo
llevó a que eso también era útil para
ser un buen presidente pero bueno déjame
platicar ahora un poco de que veremos en
la lista de geometría en la lista de
geometría justo vamos a seguir los pasos
de euclides es decir vamos a aprender a
demostrar rigurosamente algunas cosas
vamos a hacer lo que utilices hizo como
hace dos mil trescientos años pero ahora
desde un punto de vista más moderno
vamos a afinar nuestro pensamiento para
que podamos decir cuando ya demostramos
algo y cuando no y esto en realidad es
lo que más se parece a las matemáticas
profesionales
se hacen en las áreas de la ciencia
hasta ahora sólo hemos visto un poco de
aritmética y de álgebra pero eso
simplemente es hacer cuentas ahora con
geometría euclidiana ahora sí vamos a
tener una probadita real de las
matemáticas vamos a empezar con algunas
suposiciones y a partir de ellas vamos a
deducir otras
vamos a ir probando algunos teoremas y
vamos a probar cada vez más y más cosas
para hacer una pirámide bien bonita de
conocimiento